[Music]
finally tonight this week's notable
quotables
to what do you owe this recent openness
to talk me president from step you admit
kim jonghwan i'm a steel is still you
don't have steel you don't have a
country if you put tariffs against your
allies one wonders who the enemies are i
like conflict I like watching it I like
seeing it let's not bother to be
delicate did she have a sexual
relationship with the president yes he's
coming off as a angry thirteen-year-old
kid who hates daddy Trump and doesn't
want to respect mommy Muller this is
Gary Cohen's last meeting he may be a
globalist but I still like him there's
nobody left that can tame Trump's wacko
impulses let's arm-wrestle come on we
have a problem this is a political stunt
you want the money you can have the
sanctuary cities the NRA as it exists
today they have in essence become a
terrorist organization this ongoing
effort of Russians it's always good to
have a paper backup system the serious
investigations don't leave go get Dakin
go push those Democrats
it seems no one's at home in the White
House right now believe me everybody
wants to work in the White House because
we have energy like rarely before this
is March Madness its March Madness
[Applause]